So my question is what are the tips
uh for me to learn at school to strive
to strive in the path of Allah visa
and
what is um
yeah what um what are the tips as the
question what are the trips for him to
strive in the way of Allah subhana wa
t'ala maybe you
>> other than learning
>> other than learning learning what
>> learning at school
>> okay what are the tips to strive in the
way of Allah other than learning school
if you really want to strive in the way
of Allah as I said in my talk the best
striving is to become a dai
>> as Allah says in the Quran in surah
fusil 41:33
woman
Who is better in spirit than one who
invites to the way of thy lord works
righteousness says that I'm a Muslim in
our school we have a school in Bombay
education for both the worlds and my son
gave a talk four days back in solo sura
we teach children from the age of three
how to strive in the way of Allah we
teach them Arabic and English Quran had
shar from the age of Three. Striving in
the way of Allah. Doing jihad.
You know what the meaning of jihad is?
>> Yes, I know. Strive in the struggling.
>> Yes. Struggling in the
>> way of Allah. And we also teach them
martial arts. Every child when he
reaches standard five, he become the
black belt.
Every girl, every boy, by the time they
reach standard five, they become black
belt in karate, in tuando, in judo. All
my three children, two daughters and my
son even far she far he's a black belt
mashallah keep fit for doing jiad not
kal jiad is of various type to strive
and struggle we have a platform by the
name of alhaya which I call it as the
halal Netflix if you go and type al-haya
a l h i d a y a h alhaya it's a platform
where there is a course called as let's
become become effective di if you do
that course inshallah it will get you
closer and it will make you strive
harder in the way of Allah subhana wa
t'ala go to that website inshallah it
will be helpful it's a full course it's
many ask inshallah and I pray to Allah
that may you become a successful and
effective d inshallah
>> I have another question
>> one question go behind the queue now
>> and come in the right queue Muslims only
one question non-Muslim we allow so you
go back in the queue. If time permits,
you can ask